Speaker 1: Speaking of Ron DeSantis versus Donald
Trump. Fox News and FOX and Friends specifically
continues to sort of take this approach of softly
and subtly pointing more in the direction of this
of DeSantis than Donald Trump. I'm going to play
for you. This is a couple of minutes long, but
it's worth looking at this in its in its totality.
I'm going to play for you a couple minutes segment
from this morning's Fox and friends in which Steve
Doocy, Ainsley EARHARDT and Brian KILMEADE. I'm
reminding myself of their names as I as i look
at them here, spend a couple of minutes with
sort of erratic word salads. Really unclear what
the direction of this segment was. It was about
polling, it was about these different things.
But eventually they get to another subtle push
towards DeSantis and away from Trump. And the one
they come up with today is Biden would rather run
against Trump than DeSantis. Or put a different
way, the way Brian KILMEADE puts it is Biden
is more scared of DeSantis than he would be of
Trump. And it's another way to subtly suggest,
as Fox News has increasingly been doing,
subtly, they're not abandoning Trump,
but they're subtly pointing to DeSantis. DeSantis
would be the stronger candidate because Biden
would rather run against Trump. Let's let's
really dig into this, because there's a lot here.
Speaker 2: I understand that people want to
dismiss bad polls, but his response yesterday
to Judy Woodruff was, you have 50 people on
a cell phone saying they're unhappy about
the direction of the country. You don't really
care about that. Okay. If the polls were good,
if they were fine, you'd be like the polls show
people who approve of the economy was referring
to. The fact is that most people say 50% in the
last Gallup poll, 50% say they are worse off
this year than last year, and 70% believe
they were heading in the wrong direction.
Speaker 3: The country said they're
living paycheck to paycheck,
inflation picks up, gas prices are up.
Speaker 1: And now understand that two
thirds of the country living paycheck to paycheck
isn't a new thing. Four years ago, I told you and
remember who was president then that something
like half of Americans would need to borrow money
if they got hit with an unexpected $400 expense.
So a lot of this stuff isn't new. For a long time,
many Americans have felt the country is going in
the wrong direction. But you can see that they're
sort of struggling to come up with a story. And
eventually the story they shift to is Biden is
more scared of DeSantis than he is of Trump.
Speaker 3: They're down there up from
where they were when he took office.
Speaker 4: It's just crazy. And so the
president is going to Tampa today. This is the
second time in two months the president or the
vice president have been down in Florida.
Speaker 3: Why is that? Is it because
DeSantis, they're worried about that or.
Speaker 2: Maybe senior communities, too?
Speaker 4: Well, what they're trying to
do is. Exactly. And so the dissenters,
Democratic strategists expect the president to
set the stage for a reelection and draw a contrast
with Ron DeSantis. You know, he's drawn
comparisons to Donald Trump in the past,
but now it looks like and speaking of polls, you
see these polls and Ron DeSantis is surging. It's
like, okay, forget about Trump for right now.
Let's let's go ahead and go down to where Ron
DeSantis is and talk about saving all this stuff.
Speaker 3: Florida was a purple state and now
it's completely red. We saw that 19.
Speaker 4: Points Ron DeSantis won
in a landslide. So it'll be interesting.
Speaker 3: To see going down the path to,
say, Florida in their minds and bringing back.
Speaker 2: Well, I think that he's got it.
He's got a message, an area that he feels as
though is experiencing good economic times,
number one. Number two, seniors he wants to
continue to say. Harp on that inaccurate message
that Republicans want to get rid of and sunset
Medicare and Social Security and add something
else. As good as Ron DeSantis is doing, even
though he's getting a compact together, it looks
like he's going to run. Right. Donald Trump still
beating him in most polls. And in fact, I think
he's a solid second. But Trump still up front.
And I just want you on some level, if President
Biden rather have Trump, then then to say, well.
Speaker 1: So there it is. Would Biden prefer
Trump rather than DeSantis? And so this is part of
the they have built an ejector seat, so to speak,
so that if it comes to it that Donald Trump is
not the nominee, they want to get away from Trump
as quickly as possible, and they would rather
move beyond Trump and go to DeSantis. But they
can't just bail all together because Trump indeed
might be the nominee. And if Trump is the nominee,
he might indeed be the president again. And Fox
News doesn't want to want to lose access. But
this is now like the sixth or seventh sort of
segment that we've seen from Fox and Friends,
where they're either doing the man on the street
interviews, where they happen to bump into all
Republicans who want to Santos over Trump or
they're talking about polling or whatever the
case may be, they are continuing. The subtle
push away from Trump and towards the center is
what exactly their motivation is. You know, some
say it's because Rupert Murdoch personally really
doesn't like Trump. Others say it's because
they see the writing on the wall or it would
be better for them for this. That the other
thing I don't really know what the answer is.
I don't think it's completely clear. And it may
be different for different people at Fox News,
but they are setting themselves up to be right
in there with a hypothetical DeSantis nominee
or DeSantis administration. But they've got
to play it safe. And so this is the sort of
stuff that they're doing. What do you believe
is Fox's motivation and end game? Let me know
info at David Pakman dot com or leave a
comment. If you're watching on YouTube
or Facebook or Instagram. We'll take a very
quick break and much more coming up after this.